[موسيقى]
اذا كنت من المهاجرين ذوي البشره السوداء
في تونس فقد تكون جزءا من ترتيب اجرامي
لتوطين الافارقه فيها ولتغيير الطابع
الديموغرافي للبلاد الكلام للرئاسه
التونسيه يوم جمعت المجلس القومي في شهر
فبراير من العام 2023
لمناقشه الاجراءات العاجله التي يجب
اتخاذها لمعالجه مسمته ظاهره توافد عدد
كبير من المهاجرين غير النظاميين
تونس الرسميه نظريه الاستبدال العظيم قبل
ان تعود وتستنكر الاتهامات التي وجهت
اليها بالعنصريه وهل تحول التمييز الى
مجرد راي واصبح التعصب وكره الاجانب مبررا
للدفاع عن الوطن والهويه هل تم التطبيع مع
خطاب الكراهيه في تونس خطاب تدعيته سلبيه
على اقتصاد البلاد ونسيجه الاجتماعي عدا
انه يكلف شريحه كبيره من المهاجرين
الافارقه هناك سلامتهم الشخصيه ولقمه
عيشهم في فلك الممنوع
بعد وصوله الى هنا بدات واشعر بعد الرضاعه
او خمسه اشهر يجب ان اقول انني لست مرتاحا
هنا على سبيل المثال تعرضت للضرب في
الحافله لانني طلبت ان يرد لي السائق
نقودي لكنه قال انني لم اعطيه اي شيء
وانهال علي اخوته بالضرب قيل لنا ان تونس
بلد قانون لكن حقوقنا مهدوره فقط لاننا
طردني
تعرضت ايضا للاعتداء في احد المتاجر وانا
حامل في الشهر الرابع
قاموا بضربنا
كانوا يصرخون عودوا من حيث جئتم
في فلك الممنوع عن العنصريه والنقاشه عن
تونس ومع ضيوف وضيفات من تونس ابدا من هنا
من باريس مع الناشطه التونسيه في مجال
محاربه العنصريه والباحثه في المعهد
العربي للبحوث والدراسات السياسيه في
باريس مها عبد الحميد اهلا بك مهما
تصريحات رئيس تونسي قيس سعيد حول
المهاجرين الافارقه توجهت اليه برساله
مفتوحه من مواطنه تونسيه سوداء كما
عنونتها
برايك هل بدا اثر هذه التصريحات او هل فتح
الباب امام تطبيع العنصريه في تونس ام ان
الرئيس التونسي ربما فهم بشكل خاطئ كما
قيل من قبل البعض
في الحقيقه
التطبيع مع هذه النوعيه من العنصريه فتح
قبل خطاب الرئيس وخاصه منذ النشاطات التي
قام بها حزب
القومي التونسي على جميع شبكات التواصل من
فيسبوك من تويتر
حملات لطرد المهاجرين وهي في الحقيقه يعني
يعني حملات جيشت الراي العام او جزء كبير
من الراي العام وهذا بما انه الرئيس ايضا
يستمع الى مشاغل شعبه استمع الى مشاغل
مجموعه من هذا الشعب
المجموعه او جزء من هذا الشعب الذي جيشه
هذا الحزب قبل يعني تقريبا سنتين او ثلاثه
هو حزب مع كان يشتغل وفجاه يعني يظهر
للفضاء العام
فمع الاسف هذا يعني كان الخط ربما اعطى
الشرعيه الى من لديه
ارضيه خصبه للتعامل العنصري ان يطبقها على
عين المكان وبالتالي راينا عدد يعني
الانتهاكات الانتهاكات في جسد وفي كرامه
المهاجرين في بلدنا تونس هذا البلد اللي
كان يعني معروف افقيا باحترام ولشعوب
بتخاطبه
وحوار السلم مع الشعوب كان اول بلد يعني
في العالم العربي وفي المغرب العربي
يقطع مع العبوديه ومع بشكل خاطئ قيس سعيد
برايك لانه عاد وتراجع يعني وقال ان
الافارقه اشقاء وانه لم يقصد او لم يكن
الهدف من الخطاب العنصريه لا لا لا لا لم
يوصف بشان خاطئ هو الخطاب كان صريحا يعني
كان صريحا وواضحا لكن هذه العوده على ما
قيل لانه الضغوط كانت من الداخل يعني كان
المجتمع المدني حاضرا لان يكون فطنا لمثل
هذه الخطابات التي قد يعني تذهب بناء الى
ما لا يحمد عقباه ومع الاسف هي ذهبت بناء
الملامه
وداخليا وخارجيا اليوم تونس يعني اصبحت
تشع خارجا على اعتبار انها عنصريه دوله
وهذا خطير جدا دعيني استمع الى راي
المحامي والامين العام المساعد
في حراك 25 جويليه احمد الركروكي من تونس
العاصمه اهلا بك احمد
برايك لماذا اقدم رئيس تونسي على هذا
التصريح وعلى هذه التصريحات التي صدمت
العالم يعني هل هناك اليوم ما يمكن ان
يبرر هذه التصريعات تصريحات في عصرنا
الحديث في هذا العصر الذي تحارب فيه
العنصريه على مستوى دول وعلى مستوى هيئات
امميه هل يمكن ان ن جد ما يبرر هذا الخطاب
او هذه التصريحات خطاب الرئيس قيس سعيد
قائد مسار 25 جويليه هو ليس بالمستحدث او
الحديث
ودليلنا على ذلك هو قانون الاجانب الذي
ينظم تواجد اشقائنا واخوتنا الافارقه في
تونس فهناك الاقامه المؤقته وكذلك الاقامه
الدائمه ولكل لها شروط يجب احترامها اما
ما سمعته من ضيفتك الكريمه عن عوده
للعنصريه وهذا ابيض وهذا اسود فهو زمن قد
ولى منذ القدم لان اخواننا الافاق لا
نميزهم لا على لون وعلى صفه بل هم محترمون
طالما يحترمون طالما يحترمون
تواجدهم داخل بلادنا فالضيف يكرم ولا يهم
فمن اتى للدراسه فمرحبا به ومن اتى
للسياحه
انا نواصل فكرتي ولا هالحق طبعا طبعا ومن
اتى للعمل كذلك ان كانت تربط تربطنا
اتفاقيه او معاهده فمرحبا به وما اتى
للسياحه كذلك فهي الف مرحبا ومن كان
تواجده غير مبرر فبلاده اولى به فنحن
امكانيه ضعيفه بلدنا خارجه من ازمه
اقتصاديه
ولدتها سياسه عشريه سوداء ظالمه وفاجره
نحن نعاني وابناؤنا تعاني البطاله ابناؤنا
اولى بالعمل وكما يقول المثل التونسي لا
تجوز الصدقه
مع ذلك لا لا مع ذلك ليس بلا من متطرف مع
ذلك مرحبا باخواننا الافارقه فتونس جزء من
افريقيا وافريقيا كذلك جزء من تونس
وبالتالي هم اخوتنا بالامس واليوم وغدا
ولكن كلمه اختي طيب
سنناقش بعد قليل يعني لم تجبني على ناحيه
ربما البعد العنصريه الذي حملته هذه
التصريحات والذي علق عليه يعني علقت عليه
الامم المتحده هو الجانب العنصري
الخطاب خل نتفق انه الخطاب الخطاب اول من
عديد الزوايا
ساعود اليك سابقى في تونس العاصمه ولكن مع
مع الباحثه في العلوم السياسيه ياسمين
عكريم يا اهلا بك ياسمين يعني انت عملتي
على اطروح الدكتوراه عن العنصريه في تونس
ما بعد الاستقلال من خلال تجربه النساء
السوداوات تونس التونسيات
اردت التعليق ربما على ما تفضل به الاستاذ
احمد قبل ان اسالك تفضلي
يظهر نبدا ونحطه الامور في اطارها علشان
نحكيه اليوم العنصريه في تونس وفي
المجتمعات العربيه الاسلاميه ليس فقط
طعمنا نحكي على المج العربيه الاسلاميه هي
ظاهره قديمه هي ظاهره مترسخه وعندها تاريخ
واضح معناتها تونس كانت جزء من الرقه عبر
الصحراء اللي هو كلمه مع الرقه عبر الاطلس
مش بنفس العدد مش بنفس الحده ولكن معناتها
العنصريه ضد السود بالذات عندها تاريخ
ومتجذره معناتها في تونس اليوم ما نظنش
حتى حد ينجم ينفي اللي هناك عنصريه
وامساكن ماهرك مع سعديه مصباح كيما العديد
من من النساء والرجال السود في تونس احكوا
عليه ويحكيو عليه واليوم مثلا نقولوا اللي
ما فماش عنصريه مجتمعيه يظل هروب عن
الحقيقه الثاني حاجه اللي هي الاهم واللي
هي موضوعنا اليوم هو البعد السياسي
والمنعرج الخطير
ليله 21 فيفري معاه بيان الرئاسه عندما
تتحدث عندما تتحدث معها ياسمين عندما
تتحدث معها عن عنصريه الدوله اليست ربما
مبالغه بعض الشيء ام لا بالنسبه اليك
كانت تكون كانت تكون مبالغه قبل
البيان الرئيسي يقبل 21 فيفري صحيح كان
تكون مبالغه معناتها مثلا تونس بافريقيا
الجنوبيه ولا بمصاري في الولايات المتحده
مش نفس نوعا تاع المنهج الحكم لكن الان مع
الحديث في خطاب رسمي وفي بيان رسمي على
الاستبدال العظيم
ولا مش خطاب مثلا كلمه الاثارقه اللي يحكي
عليها الاستاذ
نحن افارقه تونس بلد افريقي واليوم مثلا
في خطاب الرئيس حتى فيما بعد الاستدراك
الامر قال انا لست عنصري لدي اصدقاء فارقه
هذا يوريك معناتها الى اي حد نحن عنا
معناتها استبعاد للبعد الافريقي للهويه
التونسيه وهذا في صميم يعني البحث نتاعي
اليوم في تونس على سؤال
اساسيا هذا هو السؤال الاساسي اليوم هو
يعني يعني سؤال عن الهويه
فقط على ضيفتنا الرابعه والاخيره من تونس
العاصمه ايضا الصحفيه في بيوت ساره بن علي
اهلا بك ساره عملتي على هذا الملف كثيرا
في تونس ليس فقط يعني حاليا في الاونه
الاخيره ولكن ايضا منذ وقت اطول وثقت ايضا
انتهاكات التي حصلت للعديد من المواطنين
والمقيمين من ذوي البشره السوداء اليوم
طلبت من صانعي السياسات العامه في بلادك
ان يقدموا ادله بالارقام حول ملف
المهاجرين وجهتي لهم اتهامات بالكذب على
الراي العام في هذا الملف هلا شرحت لنا
وجهه نظرك في هذا الاطار وهل تعتبرين انه
ملف يستخدم الملف العنصريه سياسيا اليوم
في تونس النقطه الاولى يمكن لازمني نفرق
مابينات دوري كصحفيه ودوري كمواطنه تونسيه
معناها الكلام اللي قلته قلته في وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي قلت
كسر المواطنه التونسيه لكن
المقالات اللي نكتبهم تقارير اللي يصورهم
هذيك خدمتك صحفيه وانا نعتبر انه اليوم
ما نجمش نفرق ما بيناتهم برشا وقت فما قمع
لحقوق الانسان في تونس وهنا فضلت نفضل اني
نجي معكم باش نفرح ببليدي باش نجيب اخبار
ايجابيه لكن للاسف بيان كيما هكا اللي هو
صار عنده جمعتين يقولوا لنا كصحافه علاش
قعدوا وقعدتوا
في الاخبار
ونمشيو لليمين المتطرف في بيان رسمي
تاريخ تونس اللي تمسخ اليوم دونك ما نجموش
نتجاوزوه ما نجموش نعملوا عليه مش موجود
دونك انا فما نقطتين نحب نجوب عليهم
النقطه الاولى نطالب
وزير العدل وزير الداخليه انه يخرجوا لنا
ارقام واحصائيات خاطرنا كي نحكي على سياده
الدوله ونحكي على استراتيجيه الدوله ونحكي
على بيان تقول قرار سياسي لجيش الناس على
على المهاجرين جنوب الصحراء اللي عايشين
في تونس وحتى على التوانسه سود البشر كي
نحكي على قرار لازم يخرج من الرابور من
دراسه يخرج من من ارقام تثبت لي انه كميه
الاجرام كما قال السفير تونس بالكونغو قال
كميه الاجرام تاع المهاجرين هذوما كبيره
برشا اعطيني ارقام اثبت لي لقاعه
نتحدث معك هل سياسه الدوله هذه الجائزه او
سياسه الدوله هذه اجراميه النقطه الثانيه
سامحني لازم نجاوب الاستاذ خاطر ما نعرفش
كان هل هو يجهل الواقع او يتجه للواقع
خاطر انت تقول لي فما قوانين وانا اطلعت
عليهم القوانين اللي ينظموا
الاقامه بتاع المهاجرين من جنوب الصحراء
والا من شمال وفرنسيس وامريكا
لكن احنا في تونس اقتنعنا كلمه اسمها ايه
في تونس كلمه اسمها التفعيل القانون هو
القانون كيخرج نورمال يتفعل
اللي انا هبطت عملت تقرير صحفي وصورته
وخرج مع ناس اللي هما جاوب بطريقه نظاميه
لتونس اللي هما يصبوا اوراقهم كاملين عند
عند السلطات المختصه ومن بعد يقعدوا
مهاجرين جنوب الصحراء ماليين من الكوت
ديفوار من البلدان الكل على خاطر الدوله
التونسيه والاداره التونسيه معناها نخصها
بالذكر تكركر تدوسي
في الكلمه
تونسيه زادت تتاخر مش انها تجاوبني على
دوسيتي فيما بالك شخص الحلقه الاضعف انه
هو يطلب اوراقه باش ينجم يتحرك باش كي
يعملوله يوقفوا بوليسي في الشارع يقولوا
اعطيني اوراقك ما عنده حتى ورقه تضبط اللي
هو سب دوسي
احمد
سالت السيد احمد ان يجيب عليه ان يجيب
تفضل استاذ احمد السؤال موجه لك تفضل تفضل
السبب معناتها هل الثوره هذه على الموضوع
هذا والغليان مرده امران
دخولهم الغريب والكثير كان باعداد كبيره
منذ 2011
واكثرهم كانوا قادمون من ليبيا
نحن مشكله ذكرت الضيف الكريمه
وانا كمحامي نبت العديد منهم
كمجرمين داخل الوقت المحاكم وانا الحي
اللي نسكن فيه كذلك في تونس في عديد من
الافرقه وهم اصدقاء لي
واذكر الاخت الكريمه ان القضايا المتعلقه
بهم هم ثلاث انواع اما قضايا حيل او تزوير
جوازات سفر او
الاتجار هل يمكن التعميم اليوم يعني تتحدث
عن التعلم على على كل المهاجرين هذا النوع
من الجناح يعني هي الحكومه اسمعني الكلمه
اختي الكريمه
يعني عندما تقول هذا الامر عن شريحه من
الناس
اختي اختي الغاليه اختي الغاليه خلينا
نكمل فكرتي انا اعطيتك من ملفاتي التي
اطلعت عليها كمحامي او عن طريق الاستماع
في بعض الزملاء في ملفات مشابهه لها
وبالتالي وزاره العدل ولديها من يمثلها هي
المطالبه وكما كانت الضيف الكريمه وزاره
الداخليه لها من يمثلها وتعطي الارقام لكن
عندما نتحدث عن جمعيه المئه نبي المؤسسه
في اريانا والتي تدعو الى دين جديد لا
علاقه له لا بالدين الاسلام سمح ولا
بالديانه اليهوديه ولا بالديانه المسيحيه
ولا بجميع الديانات بها عالميا وهو يعتبر
نوع من الشذوذ الديني الذي لا علاقه لنا
به لانه نحن بلد الاسلام بلدنا التونسي هو
مسلم
ويحترم جميع الديانات الاخرى
ولكن هناك مشكله اساسيه سيدي الكريم انت
تعمم يعني المشكله انني لا يمكن ان اسمح
في البرنامج ان يتم تعميم هذا النوع من
الاتهامات على مجموعه مهوله من البشر هذا
امر يعني غير اخلاقي بالنسبه لهذا
البرنامج ولكن سادعت ساضعك تكمل بناء على
على
قلت طبيعه الجرائم بناء على ما تفضلت به
فقط بناء على ما تفضلت به
نتفاعل الورق قلت رايك طيب طيب تفضل
باختصار يعني خلص فكرتك باختصار خلص فكرتك
استاذ احمد تفضل
الغير شرعي مش الشرعي لانه كيما سبقوا
قلنا جاري الدراسه مرحبا به واللي جاري
العمل وفق معاهدات ومواثيق قانونيه مرحبا
به ومن قدم من جنوب الصحراء ودخل خلصه
لتراب التونسي في بلاده اولى به
نطالبو دول العالم والدول القويه ان
تمنحنا من المال كي نؤطرهم بحكم تونس
عندها الكفاءات العلميه ثم نعيدهم
نظريه استخدام انت اليوم تؤكد نظريه
استخدام نقطه ضعف هذه الشريحه من البشر من
اجل جلب المال للدوله التونسيه هناك من
يقول ان هذه يعني اليوم
اقول انا قلت لك تونس دوله فقيره دوله
تونس تونس دوله فقيره
ولا تستطيع ان تثقل ساعدها باشياء اكبر من
ميزانيتها احنا عنا اولادنا
ياسمين اتفضل
انا نحب
نعقب على المداخله بتاع الاخ او الحاجه
اولا هو كمحامي يستعمل يعني عبارات
متحامله جدا على منوي به نحن عندما
المحامي حتى قاتل النفس حتى اكبر معنتها
مجرم في العالم عندما
ينوب محامي لا يقول له المحامي مجرما
وانما يقول وانما من فضلك انا مقصدش عليك
سامحني خليني نكمل المحامي عندما ينوبه او
ينوبه او ينوب معناتها موكل لا يقول مجرم
هو نعتهم بالمجرمون هم امام القضاء الى ان
يعني متهمين على الاقل على الاقل
هناك ربما
اخلاقيات المهنه
حبيت نقولها اللي ملف منشور
بارك الله فيك
بين ليله وضحاها الناس هذوما هم نفسهم
لليوم يقولوا الاخوه الافارقه مش معناتها
الاخوه الافارقه اسعد تونس كلنا
معناتها الاخوه الافارقه اللي هم عطاوهم
اسم يعني عنصري جدا قال لك نحن الافارقه
في جنوب في شمال افريقيا وهم ما يسموا
الاجاصيين الاجاصيين وهي معناتها تقسيم
لكلمه افريقيا جنوب الصحراء يعني حتى
التعبير يعني التعبير عنصري وتعبير فيه
يعني تقسيم لهذا المكون الجغرافي الافريقي
لا اتحدث عنك ما اتحدث عن ما وقع وعن من
يساندهم ايضا معناتها الخطاب الذي يحمل
خطابهم والذي يريد اليوم ان يعود هؤلاء
المهاجرين الى ارضهم اليوم قبل غد نحن
ايضا عندما يقوم يتكلم اليمين المتطرف في
فرنسا وفي البلدان الاوروبيه لاعاده كل
التونسيين اللي يحرقوا من 2011 الى 2023
واللي هم التوا في وضعيه غير قانونيه سوف
معناتها نسمعوكم شنو باش تقولوا نسمعكم
شنو هو الراي متاعكم في هذه الخطاب
العنصري هل الخطاب المتطرف اللي خرجتوا به
في تونس واللي احنا معاش نحبه نسمعوه
بصراحه
فالنقطه الثانيه اللي في ما يخص يعني
الوضعيه المهاجرين في تونس السيد يقول
هاتونا الفلوس
من نحن لن نؤثر يعني افريقيا وما ادراك
معناتها البلدان الافريقيه غنيه بما لديها
حتى في افريقيا جنوب الصحراء
حتى جنوب افريقيا جنوب الصحراء حتى
بافريقي جنوب الصحراء
الى بلدانهم عندهم ثروات عديده انت مواطن
انت مواطن تتحكم فقط في بيتك انت مواطن
تتحكم في منزلك
والمربع الذي حول منزلك ولا تتحكم في
الارض التونسيه هناك هناك
انت انت قيادي
وليس ايجا سياسيه
هي من لها معاهداتها وهي التي تعرف كيف
تتعامل مع الدول
دفعتم انتم بهذه الخطابات العنصريه بهذه
الخطابات
على الرئيس ان يسوق لهذا الخطاب العنصري
وان يسوق الى صوره تونس الذي اصبحت اليوم
صوره غير مشرفه لنكهوانسه كفوا عن هذا هل
هذا الخطاب العنصري كي نسمع بعض ياسمين لو
سمحتي كلمه مختصره قبل ان نذهب لنستمع الى
راي الشارع ميرسي احنا التوبه ربي سامحني
اختي خلينا نتكلم خاطر وقت اللي نتكلم
احنا على العنصريه وقت نتكلموا على واقع
يعني ملموس باش يتهمونه يتهمونا بالعقد
ويتهمونا بالمرض والله انا ما نعرفش شكون
المريض اللي هو ما يستوعبش الانسانيه في
كلها والا الاشكوني المريض هذوم الناس
ليست لهم حجج يقذف كل يقذفون موجود لا
وجود الاشكال اسم عنصر موجود موجود موجود
العنصريه
مرحبا بهم انت افريقيا
هل انت افريقي
لو سمحت
اريد ان اسالك هل انت لو سمحتم لو سمحتم
سيد احمد سؤالي انا لك لو سمحت هل تعتبر
انك افريقي في مكان ما من هويتك ام لا
يعني تقول اخواننا الافارقه انت هل تعتبر
بطبيعه اوكي
لو سمحتي
نكمل
باولا الاستاذ يضحكني خطر يقول مرحبا بهم
هم اخواتنا يقول لهم
غير الشرعيين
مثلا خلينا نكمل
تونس اليوم
فما فارقه من جنوب الصحراء في تونس علاش
على خاطر تونس خاضعه وتونس منخرطه في
سياسات هجره الاتحاد الاوروبي سياسات هجره
الاتحاد الاوروبي
تونسيه الطائله وهي منخرطه نحن منخرطين من
قبل 2011 من فتره بن علي من اخر التسعينات
رانا منخرطين وقابلين قابلين نحرصوا
الحدود الاوروبيه انت قابل الحاجه وانت
تقبل في الاعانات وتستقبل في الاعانات
تستقبل في الفلوس لازمك تحط اطار قانوني
للعباد اللي يقعدوا لك عليش على خاطر تقول
لي مثلا قانون 68 قانون 68 قانون قديم وفي
الواقع في الواقع كيما قالت ساره العباد
تقعد بال 11 شهر باش تاخذ رخصه
اقامه اليوم سعيد برشا لاي معناتها مهاجر
باش يقعد في تونس
هديه سولك الدوله في استنكار معناتها
الدوله تخف في فلوس باش تقوم بمناوله
معناتها سياسات هجره الاتحاد الاوروبي
ولكن هي في استنكار للوقعه على خاطر
البحر الابيض المتوسط
وتستقر ولازم نكونوا عنا اطار قانوني يسمح
للناس اخواتنا الافارقه كما نحكيو عليهم
باش يعيشوا معناتها بطريقه
معناتها شرعيه وبطريقه مع تحفظ الكلام
نتاعهم على خاطر
اللي صاير هو الدوله قاعده باختصار الدوله
قاعده تمنع في العباد يخرجوا على خاطر
عندها املاءات خارجيه ولكنها هي في
استنكار للوضع الداخلي ما تسمحش العبيد
الشغل ولا للعيش بطريقه شرعيه يعني انت
تقولين ان الدوله تستفيد من هذا الملف في
مكان ما ماديا لكنها لا تعطي في المقابل
الخدمات او الاجراءات التي يجب ان يتم
اعطائها لهؤلاء المهاجرين طيب كيف استقبل
الشارع التونسي وشوارع من عواصم عربيه
اخرى تصريحات الرئيس قيس سعيد حول
المهاجرين الافارقه نستمع معا ثم اذهب
اليك يا ساره ما يكذبش على حتى حد الرئيس
قيس سعيد وتونسي ويحب تونسي وهذيك مؤامره
نراها على التوانسه وعلى الشعب التونسي
وعلى رئيس دوله احنا الخطاب هذا
[موسيقى]
الرئيس التونسي تصريحات محترمه جدا ممكن
البعض يفهمها غلط لكن لازم ان احنا
عنصري انا
نفسي على الشعب التونسي
كحاجه
طبعا
رئيس الدوله يحكي على الشعب التونسي ككتله
كامله وهو يمثلها لاننا ما نحبش نعمل نهبط
في الخطا اللي قام به رئيس الدوله في
الكوسوفي في الانتخابات والا في بعض في
البيانات متاعه كيفاش استقبلت الاراء في
تونس نعيش في تونس وانا من عائله تونسيه
ومنجموش ننكره انه فمك كلام عنصري وفما
جهويات وفما برشازينوفوبيا معناها كره
الاخر خوف من الاخر على خاطر ولهنا ولهنا
باش نرجع على كلمه قالها الاستاذ قال تونس
دوله فقيره هذيك علاش لازم يمشيو لبلدان
اخرين اللي هما عندهم اكثر فلوس تونس ليست
دوله فقيره تونس تم تفقيرها تفقيرها باتم
معنى الكلمه سياسيا اجتماعيا ثقافيا في
الدراسه البرامج الدراسيه نتاعنا التوامت
بدلت
في تحكي مع شخص عاش في حومته فما فما
يخرجوش منهم
باش نفهم الموضوع من حيث
السينما كما في كل العالم
ولكن اليوم اليوم هناك ايضا من يقول ان
يعني هناك وكنت ساسال السيد احمد عن هذا
الموضوع سيدي احمد هناك يعني اليوم منظمات
دوليه عالميه لحقوق الانسان لمناهضه
العنصريه يعني تعتبر ان للاسف العنصريه هي
من الا التي تعاني منها المجتمعات كثيره
في العالم ومنها المجتمعات العربيه
كالمجتمع التونسي وهو حديثنا اليوم يعني
هناك هذه الافه موجوده انت تقول عكس هذا
الامر بناء على ماذا خطاب العنصري هو
موجود منذ الازل ولكن يتفاوت من دوله الى
دوله اخرى نسب نتاعه انا من اعتقدش ان
الخطاب العنصري موجود في تونس بدليل سبب
المهاجرين الذين هربوا الى بلدانهم بدلوا
الخطاب
اختي الغالي احنا نحكو على الهجره الغير
شرعيه احنا تاذينا منها في العشريه
السوداء اللي تم تفقير فيها تونس كما كانت
معناتها الاخت فضلت وقالت اني تونس فقير
ولكن في العشريه السوداء في العشريه
السوداء انا اتفق معها ولكن نحن توفي ازمه
والازمه تعالج بحلول مش نزيد نعنق الازمه
وبالتالي وقت اللي استقر الوضع الاقتصادي
والسياسي في تونس فمرحبا حتى لا غير شرعي
في نطاق المحدود في نطاق المحدود اما دوله
لدينا حدود لو كان الشرعي وبعض من
الشرايين
وهم يتزايد
اليوم
وصل وصل
ان نتحدث انا كقيادي في حرك 25 يتحدثوا
باسم
ما امثل بس مسكون احنا ما كتبنا الجهويه
والمحليه في كل مكان واعضاءنا في البرلمان
موجودين اتحدث باسم الشعب لاني انا جزء
انا من الشعب امام متمثلني سامحني
نمثل نسبه من الشعب كله
وانت حره شكرا تمثلين نفسك
طيب
يا سيد احمد الموضوع كيفيه التعامل مع هذا
الملف بشكل عنصري لماذا اليوم يطرح هذا
الملف من باب العنصليه
سوف نتعامل سوف نتعامل بشكل
يا اختي الغاليه هناك قلت هناك تفضل
ساعطيك الكلمه ساره اتفضل
النسبه كبيره وبالتالي سوف نتعامل
وفي الحدود
انت يا اختي
دعيه يكمل ياسمين ساعود اليكم
اتفضل طيب اتفضل كمل ولكن هل لديك اعداد
وزاره الداخليه والحدود والاجانب انا
معطيك على نسبه عامه اما الارقام ثم اهل
الذكر والناسكل اللي سجل الحدود والاجانب
ويعطيكم النسبه انا اتحدث بما وصل لاذني
من نسب مني سب كبيره وكبيره جدا
ومن يريد ان يتاجر بملف اخواتنا الافارقه
كورقه سياسيه للضغط على الرئيس قيس سعيد
فهو واهم تونس من افريقيا وافريقيا جزء من
تونس ولكن لا ننسى ان
تواجدهم المكثف يمثل خطرا عن الامر من
القوم التونسي وبالتالي يجب مراجعه نسبه
دخولهم احنا دخولهم مع الشرايين ومع لا
غير شر كذلك
هو ان هذا الخطاب بالتحديد هو الذي ربما
يغذي هذه العنصريه ازاء هؤلاء المهاجرين
واذا الاشخاص ذوي يعني البشره السوداء
ساسال ساره باختصار لو سمحتي قبل ان اختم
معك معي تفضلي سامحني قصي تعليق على خاطر
فما مغالطه اعلاميه اللي هو رئيس الدوله
خارج مرسوم ضد المغالطات الاعلاميه للتقال
في الاعلام في تونس انه يقول لي فما تضرر
في الاقوال من هنا يقول فمن نسب كبيره
وكبيره جدا وهذا اللي سمعته ومن شراء اخرى
يقول اللي ما عندوش يقولهم واللي لازمنا
نمشيوا لاهل الذكر دونك لهنايا فما انا
عندي
من عند الدوله التونسيه ليه يا ناس اللي
هو
مركز الوطني للاحصائيات اللي يقول اللي
المهاجرين جنوب الصحراء في تونس ما يجوز
20 الف هذوما
نمشي الامم المتحده يخرجوا لي رقم اخر
يقولوا لي اللي هما 58 الف ما يفوتوش 0.5
من
تونس معناتها
كيفاش تنجم انت تقر اللي فما
وفد كبير
اعطيني الارقام وبعد تنجموا بطريقه بناء
المعطيات هذوما
العنصريه راهي منظومه ممارسه حكم وديما
موجوده لحمايه امتيازات اليوم نظريه
المؤامره في تونس واللي كان يحكي عليه
الاستاذ نتاع ارقام منعرفوهاش اما هو
اسمها اللي سمى مئات الالاف لتونس
مباشر هناك انعكاس مباشر لهذه طيب اود فقط
ان اشير
لا اريد
انعكاس مباشر لتصريحات لتصريحات الرئاسه
التونسيه على افعال الناس في الشارع تفضلي
ياسمين باختصار لو سمحت
فقط فقط نكمل الوحده بلدان افريقيه من
افريقيا جنوب الصحراء قاموا بترحيل
معناتها الجاليه نتاعهم والجاليه متاعهم
تصاور في سيغنيا مثلا عبيد خلطه تبكي هديه
ذبيحه على تونس ومنعرج خطير اليوم هديه
فكره نظريه المؤامره من غير لا ارقام من
غير لا مبرر باش نغطيوا على فشل ذريع في
اداره الازمه هذه ما تنجمش تتواصل منجموش
نهربوا الى الابد فقط استاذ احمد كلمه
اخيره ساختم معك ساره ومعك مها بعد قليل
استاذ احمد فقط للاشاره نحن لك وللمشاهدات
والمشاهدين الهدف ليس محاكمتك محاكمتك على
رايك وانما اليوم انت تمثل ربما التابو في
كل هذا النقاش ولهذا يعني
اردت فقط ان اشير الى هذا الامر لك
وللمشاهدين والمشاهدات تفضل كلمه اخيره عن
تونس غدا كيف تراها اليوم انت تقول ليس
هناك عنصريه كيف ترى تونس غدا
الصعبه التونسي الكريم وكذلك اخواننا
الافارقه وجميع دول العالم بان تونس
العظيمه في مرحله التحرر والبناء وجميع
الحقوق والحريات المحفوظه ولا وجود لميز
بين ابيض او اسود او بين فقير وغني
دستور 22
كان دستورا للشعب جميعا دون استثناء
والحكم للشعب وتونس سوف تدرس الناس درسا
في الديمقراطيه وشكرا ان تدرس الناس يعني
من قبل دروسا في الديمقراطيه وفي الحريات
تونس ونتمنى ان تبقى وان تظل كذلك ساره
كلمه اخيره قبل ان اختم
على تطبيق القانون نرجع للقانون قانون 50
لاصدار في 2018 ضد العنصريه كان رئيس دوله
يحترم القانون لازم يطبقوا على مؤسسه
مؤسسه الرئاسه خاطر خرجت بين عنصري اللي
هو قاعد يتراجع الاقوال لكن ما قالش
اعتذار معملش اعتذار اللي نعتبره معناها
واحد كيغلط لازمو يعتذر على خاطر هذيك
تشوه صوره تونس وتشوه بلادنا وتخلينا
في تطبيق القانون في سياسه الدوله متاعنا
نحب نختم زايده على كلمه الاستيطان راهو
احنا فرقه شمال الصحراء وهما فرقه جنوب
الصحراء وكان تهبطوا لتونس وتشوفوا من
اجمل المشاهد لازم تشوفوهم في تونس هي
الصحراء خاطر قاعده نظيفه والصحراء لازمها
تلمنا مش تقسمنا كيما قسمنا البحر الابيض
المتوسط مع بلدان الشمال على خاطر
العنصريه اللي قاعده تصير وتطبق على
اولادنا يخرجو لبرا على خاطر بلادنا قاعده
تتفكر دونك لازم يخرجوا لبرا باش يشوفوا
حياتهم وعلى خاطر فما زاده
الازمه المناخيه اللي جايه لتونس باش
نزيدو نتفكر المناخير دونك لهنا ان شاء
الله ان شاء الله كي نهارك بعد عمر طويل
لازمنا نضطر انه نهاج تونس باش نمشيو
لبلدان اخرين ما يستقبلوناش كيما استقبلنا
فرقه جنوب الصحراء في تونس شكرا يا ساره
مها ختام كلمه معك
اذا كان ثوره
شيء جميل هو انه اهدتنا يعني طوقنا لهذه
الكرامه الانسانيه اهدتنا حريه التعبير
اهدتنا انه نكونوا اكثر انفتاح على العالم
ليس فقط للعالم الابيض اي شمال المتوسط
وانما ايضا علمنا الداخلي داخل افريقيا
فبالتالي اذا كنا نحن نناضل من اجل
كرامتنا ونحب ان ان تحفظ هذه الكرامه
فنتقي الله في كرامه الاخرين في بلادنا
ويعني نقلص من هذا الخطاب الذي اعتبره
خطاب منافق جدا خطاب فيه كثير من النفاق
هناك لاعب على الحبلين على تونس من ان
يكون يعني المستقبل اكثر عنصريه طبعا انا
تونسيه وقفو على تونس واخاف على على
الدوليه تحياتي
[موسيقى]